hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in chapters 11 and 12 of book 3 of his
work on anger Seneca is going to suggest
to us that if we want to avoid getting
angry there's things we can do about it
we can
reframe the ways that we're looking at
things and there's a number of different
suggestions that he provides us with
that can be quite helpful and we might
actually want to ignore or Overlook
certain things I think there's a great
line at the very beginning of chapter 12
where he tells us that anger often comes
to us but more often we go to it and
what what that means is that there's
going to be anger arising quite
naturally no matter what we do and then
we can figure out how to deal with that
but in a lot of cases we're actually
creating the situation or interpreting
the situation framing the situation in
such a way that we're likely to
experience anger because we take
ourselves as being injured insulted we
you know think the motives of other
people are bad malicious aimed at
hurting us or those we care about or
even the things that we care about and
Seneca wants to say that you know we're
responsible for that and we can actually
change that so it's kind of liberating
he tells us that we should never
summon anger means never right and then
anger is never to be called for don't
say hey anger time to come to dinner
let's feast or anything like that right
now that doesn't mean that we won't ever
get angry but we can really cut down on
it quite a bit
he says that even when it comes our way
we should reject it we should push it
away and so he begins chapter 11 saying
it's not a good idea to hear and see
everything that goes on
you know we don't need to like be
constantly Vigilant we don't need to be
getting into other people's business
that doesn't concern us if somebody's
sitting on the bus and they're reading a
newspaper that we don't like or laughing
at a video that doesn't
our business right so not seeing or
hearing everything that goes on people
talking under their breath after we tell
them what to do and they're not happy
about it we don't need to pay attention
to that sort of thing and so he tells us
that the person who's not registering or
literally not knowing neskit right uh
injuries which may in fact be injuries
may not doesn't suffer them so if we're
in a line and you know we don't like
what the other people around us are
saying we don't have to pay attention to
it it's not our business we can just let
them be who they are and focus on our
own stuff and then we're not going to
get angry with them even if they're
grumbling about us or matters like that
so he tells us if you don't want to get
angry
then don't be so inquisitive and the
word that he's using there is actually
curiosis right don't be so curious don't
pry into everything that's happening
around you or and don't especially pry
into things that you you're going to
find bother you like he says the person
who asks what remarks were made about
him and Unearthed nasty gossip even if
it was Kept Secret just upsets himself
nothing made that person ask somebody
else what are they saying about me or
going online and Googling yourself oh
you know so-and-so's a jerk right you
don't have to do that that's a choice on
your part Seneca is saying so if we want
to not get angry we probably we don't
have to be completely oblivious to
everything going on around us but we
probably should you know stay in our
lane as we say and he talks about
interpreting things in a certain way
interpretation that's up to us we choose
how we regard things and the the way he
talks about it they're quite um
interpretazio it's the exact word
interpretation Quito means a kind of or
a certain right so interpreting things
in a certain way makes them look like
injuries somebody bumps into you as
you're in a crowded space and they hurry
on past you could be like ah I guess
that person isn't paying attention to
where they're going that's an
interpretation you could also go to The
Other Extreme and be like that son of a
chose to bump me and now they're
running away so I can't retaliate well
that's another interpretation right and
we can have all sorts of things well
that was just a physical contact oh that
was a malicious act all of these are our
choices of how we're interpreting things
and Seneca has a great line here
especially in the Latin right he's
talking about three different classes of
things Aliyah is one group another group
another group and he tells us that with
some things we should defer them
different so don't take any stance on
them just hang back a bit others we
should actually laugh off diridenda
right so uh this is we were supposed to
laugh them down laugh them off and
others he says we should translate it as
forgive but literally donanda Alia so we
should we should give those things to
the other person just let it go right
let it be their thing and he gives some
examples here he says when Socrates are
struck on the head he made no response
saved to say it was a bother people
didn't know and it was a good idea to
wear a helmet when leaving the house
and he goes on and he says what makes a
difference is not how an injury was
caused but how it's born how it's
carried Lata quite literally and he says
you know self-control is not that
difficult even tyrants
some tyrants he uses the example of
pisostratus who is a cruel guy but was
able to laugh when people did things and
said things
um you know people trying to light a
fire under his anger he bore it calmly
and said that those who were trying to
stir him up he was no more Furious than
if a blindfolded person had run into him
so it could be a joke could also be just
letting it go forgiving right these are
all possibilities for us these are ways
that we can take our own you know
responses and motives and say I'm going
to look at it this way and I'm going to
behave this way rather than going down
the path of anger a little bit later in
chapter 12 he tells us that we should
consider the intention in Latin animum
fociantis consider the intention the
Mind literally of the person who's doing
the thing vacantus
not just the act itself ipsum factum
right the thing that the person does so
you know again let's take the example of
bumping into you could be the same
action on the part of somebody who's
deliberately going around and filming
them bumping into people like you see
these uh interesting little short videos
of some guy who's a little bit built
going by somebody who's more built and
bumping him with his shoulder and then
walking past right that's deliberate
right
a lot of times that's not the case
people just bump into us and so we
should think about whether the action is
something voluntary something they chose
something that stems from their will or
something that is accidental they didn't
mean for it to happen and then he goes
on and he talks about two important
factors that really from Aristotle's
time onward are recognized as making an
action accidental or unintentional was
it compelled did somebody force them in
some way did their body malfunction you
know were they walking along and then
they had some sort of twitch and bumped
you or something along those lines or
they said something mean to you right or
are they deceived did somebody trick
them are they laboring under some sort
of Illusion or misinformation or
misreading of the situation are they
motivated by hatred or by by some sort
of reward premium a a bounty you could
say are they doing something essentially
to gratify themself or actually their
own character their mores as Seneca will
say or are they doing some sort of
service for other people all of these go
into the
mindset the intention of the action
that's going on so in some cases maybe
there there really is an injury you know
they hate our guts so they're trying to
go after us they're taking money for
doing something bad right it could be
voluntary right but you know in some
cases if they're compelled or they're
doing something because they think
they've got an obligation to somebody
else you know maybe we shouldn't get
angry at them Seneca is saying and so we
need to think about this
um and if we don't know maybe we should
just assume the best rather than the
worst of other people he also talks
about taking into account people's age
and their Fortune
so by Fortune somebody stealing
something from us because they need to
sell it in order to provide food for
their kids and they've tried to get jobs
and they can't find it maybe we don't
get angry at them in the same way as we
do some rich person stealing our stuff
who doesn't need it at all and it's just
satisfying their own desire to steal
things right or to dominate or to mess
with somebody age I mean younger people
often respond kind of
let's just say passionately rather than
as rationally same thing sometimes with
older people and there are many people
as Aristotle pointed out long ago who
are mature in years but immature in
their mindset and soul and then finally
He suggests that we and this is actually
quite literally what he's saying putting
ourselves in the place
of the person with whom we are getting
angry EOS knows local Loco is placed
ayo's local that that same place
constituamus let's Place ourselves in
their as we say in their shoes walking a
mile in their shoes and so he says if we
do that from that perspective we see
that an unfair valuation of ourselves
makes us angry we value ourselves too
highly we value other people to lowly
and so we get angry we can reframe that
by saying hey we're all we're all human
beings here and I can understand why
they did that action now that I've put
myself in their place in their shoes and
that'll help us to not get angry so
we've got a whole bunch of strategies
here
all connected with reframing things so
that we don't have to go down that kind
of automatic route into anger and this
allows us to free ourselves from
automatically or characteristically
getting angry at other people by
reinterpreting the situation in ways
that allow us to give them a break or to
even laugh about the matter rather than
getting angry and attempting to
retaliate